sometimes watching the movie isn't
enough you also want to eat that movie
that's why there's movie recipes today
we're with Chef Mike fuller at Ray's at
killer Creek in Atlanta Georgia we've
challenged him with making a dish
inspired by one of our old favorites
Cool Hand Luke
chef fuller has selected a list of
essential ingredients to make that
heaven they are bacon for the pigs who
locked Luke up can I say that's for a
bit eggs thankfully not 50 of them
though we're not made of steel and
pickles because like this movie
cucumbers get better with time and salt
cook the food boss
[Music]
[Applause]
Cool Hand Luke yep came out in the 60s
1967 it's actually always in those top
100 lists and everything thanks a lot
part 2 Paul Newman being amazed guys
unbelievable you want to talk about a
guy that I wanted to be man as Paul knew
that's guy that guy is amazing you know
he was so cool just on camera obviously
in this character is perfect for him
yeah
you know the whole nickname comes from
him playing poker and he's like that's
one cool hand you know and it's just a
perfect way to describe him and he's
just perpetually bemused in this movie I
think he's always got that's that Luke's
smile yeah even when he gets arrested
that at the beginning he's cutting off
the heads of the party Muniz it when he
gets arrested he's like yeah we grew up
in an era where we knew old Paul Newman
right but Paul Newman was a great actor
we knew him but I mean I watched the
sting a bunch when I was a kid that was
probably before my time but you know
everything after that has been old Paul
knew but he was handsome he was a
heartthrob and he was magnetic and
charismatic is all he raced cars he
raced cars he's not a celebrity circuit
then raced against like real racers and
one which is insane
[Music]
the scene that you were alluding to
which could be the basis of our meal
today yeah he eats 50 eggs hard-boiled
eggs in an hour in an hour not in real
life though yeah we learned during
research that he only ate eight only
eight eight yeah but that's a tough
scene to watch it is it is because they
keep throwing it down and there's a
point he's at thirty two eggs and he's
standing up he's walking around he's
like putting water on his face all her
stuff and then they start walking him
around and start stuffing eggs into his
mouth Ellie's oldest well fifty eggs
that's like six pounds you're gonna kill
that guy not my baby look I've already
[Music]
another thing that pops out to me in
this movie is the way they portray the
heat that is in this like it's another
character in itself is the heat there's
so it like the whole beginning of it
then you know I'm taking it off boss and
like they're sweaty and they're like
wiping themselves down and all that but
it's really start when you see him go to
the box for the first time and you
notice where he has to be he's gonna be
on these stones for 24 hours the heat
going through this tiny like you know
box and everything I don't know if any
movie is like portrayed heat this way
it's so aggressive yeah like you feel
like you if you could if you were like
in a cold place and watch this movie you
would by transfer again you get war
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm so happy you did this I love doubled
eggs but what are we looking at here so
these are farm-fresh deviled eggs
they have Benton's 68th ham up from
Tennessee yeah and then we do our own
bread burr pickles and we make it
vinaigrette with the pickles look so it
well the plate is visually stunning well
yes
presentation-wise and i'm the net at the
expert in that and what i almost don't
want to eat it and ruin the painting
that is on this plate yeah I will ruin
it
what are we got here in the sauces on so
that's the bread butter brown butter
pickle juice okay so the vinegar that we
used to make the pickles it's nice and
sweet and piccoli and then we make it a
vinaigrette with that with a little bit
Dijon mustard and extra virgin olive oil
why did you go with Cool Hand Luke
Cohan Luke's just an all-time favorite
it's it's one of my movies that I
remember from childhood makes me think
of my dad makes me think it's you know
it's kind of a life setting tone you
know what I mean yeah oh yeah this is
unbelievable I would try to eat 50 of
these I would not succeed yeah hmm how
do you make the stuffing mostly
everybody's got their own trick so the
stuffing yeah it's so the cooking eggs
you know there's a bunch of research on
cooking eggs and exactly the right way
to do the eggs so we have a fancy way of
cooking our eggs which is oversimplified
and then the stuffing so we take the
yolks and we press them through a sieve
and so they they come out like nice and
light and airy and kind of creamy
already and then we just mix it with
Duke mix mayonnaise and Dijon mustard
and some chopped up fresh button bar it
was amazing yeah tell us some of your
favorite scenes from the movie so
definitely the egg contest that the
eating of the eggs is definitely
definitely wasn't my favorites the
chicken the tree was great yeah it's
just a trick I was trying to explain to
the girls earlier his personality in the
movie was he's such a likable guy he's
smiling all the way through the movie
but he's kind of a scoundrel Yeah right
yeah he's easy to root for he's easy to
root for exactly so he's kind of
rebellious these are kind of a
rebellious thing my boss hates deviled
eggs we fixed a deal on the menu four or
five times you can't stand them so I'm
surprised you didn't say the carwash
scene was your favorite the car seats
pretty hot these are probably the best
deviled eggs ever absolutely
deviled eggs are generally good
regardless but I might actually want to
go on a date with these thank you so
much for this being only crap thanks
coming
[Music]